you look incredible absolutely beautiful
I want to start by congratulating you
sixteen Emmy nominations for this
program and you got the nomination for
lead actress and that's just amazing big
deal I don't know what I'm going to wear
but what I will tell you is yes you're
right it is very very stressful and
here's what happens you get nominated
and people say oh how many people are
reaching out to you to make you things
because people are supposed to make it
like famous designers yeah people say
like oh yeah I would think yeah Andy so
you're getting calls from fans designers
who wants to make but here's the thing
yeah I've got the bees I got the boobs
and I got the booty and with that well
thank you very much yeah I want to get
behind
it's also that it's a good thing you
told us cuz no one notices now yeah well
it's not a designer's dream oh they like
you a little more on the slimmer side
yeah and so I don't have a lot of offers
but I'm gonna get something figured out
yeah well first of all we we've now put
it out there right now they that people
need to design something for you is it
really that hard it really is because
you know how many sequels it takes to
wrap around all this yeah yeah yeah I'm
optimistic though yeah